hey how are you guys I just flew in and
I got some back problems like to see a
sports medicine doctor and he gave me
muscle relaxers I was like can I drink
on these and he was like absolutely I
was like are you sure and he said I'd do
it I'm like that wasn't the question are
you sure it's not gonna mess my liver up
he said he'll mess it up pretty bad I'll
think he's not my doctor anymore we do
hang out he's pretty cool but he texts
me to go to the rec center to swim to
strand to my back and a lot of weirdos
there you know I knocked on the bathroom
door and the guy in the bathroom just
yells out who is it that is not we were
supposed to say you're supposed to say
I'm in here you're not supposed to be
expecting company
in the men's rec room bathroom but I
figured I'd give it a shot so I said
it's a man he goes now what right answer
yeah I just got a text out of the blue
for my ex-girlfriend she said I just say
you know I'm seeing this new guy and I
wrote back oh wow
and then she was like what you didn't
think I was ever gonna date ever again I
said no I just didn't remember signing
up for the push notifications I'd like
to hear less from you and the Huffington
Post a possible
I'm not complaining it's a great time to
be a guy really is fantastic
the bar has never been lower all you
have to do is not take your penis out of
masturbate and women are like he's a
feminist he is clearly an ally I was
going on a date the other night in this
uh there's my friends like you going on
days like you got a masturbate before
the date cuz that way if you get laid
you last longer
here's they don't tell you though if you
masturbate before a date you were gonna
cancel that date I called the girl Mike
there's been a change of plans
you go to the movie I'm gonna take a nap
I go on this date and you know she's
telling me her last boyfriend she's Mike
she's my last boyfriend was a 60 year
old guy I was like that's pretty old for
you she said let me tell you something
there's no difference between the
30-year old dick and a 60-year old dick
I said I haven't done the research but I
feel like that's not true I feel like
there's a difference that difference
temperament a young penis is like an
intern I'll put the crack of dawn down
for whatever overeager an old penis is
like a CEO is like this better be
important don't have a lot of time
but the date goes well we're making out
in a bar she starts putting her hand
underneath my pants under the table and
she just looks at me in the eyes and
goes why aren't you erect I'll take of
erect what are you a transformer who
talks like that I'll tell you why cuz
we're kissing and I'm not thirteen
that's why have you seen the stuff
that's out there you want to get me hard
tell me you're a dental assistant your
husband's coming home in five minutes
then we'll talk she's a hot lawyer too
[ __ ] let me call the company car
I was like whoa company car so when the
company car was making out why were we
left off she goes underneath my pants
again in the car just starts undoing my
pants takes my penis out in the car
correct and and it's like you know like
this is not appropriate I thought that I
let her do it but I deserve credit for
having that awareness because there's no
partition the drivers fully reclined at
one point he just says out loud you know
there's a person driving this car I was
like wow that would be the perfect ad
for driverless cars
I do I do not like what I'm attracted to
though it's not good anymore you know
I'm too old for porn I'm realizing you
know I am you know I was watching one
the other day and my first thought while
watching it was wow that's a nice
kitchen that might be a bad sign
I'm that desensitized to people who are
having sex in front of me I'm like what
is that a stovetop grill she was like
you can finish anywhere I'm like yeah
it's stainless steel everyone knows that
thank you so much
[Applause]